close your eyes for a moment will you
please and breathe with me just close
your eyes and if you will put your thumb
to your middle finger and gather your
other fingers around and let's feel the
vibration and pulse of your personal
energy as you take three deep breaths
with me inhale and as you exhale just
feel the vibration energy blood
pulsating through your body through you
and another inhale
and another inhale
[Music]
and keep your eyes closed and let's just
think about this day
this day that you have been graced to
breathe in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breasts
were taken for granted you just expected
the next one to come but the truth is
there's no guarantee that the next one
comes this day how you started your day
what your thoughts were this morning how
you've carried yourself through this day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences some
challenging some more life enhancing
that pushed you forward another day of
being here on the planet Earth as a
human being I just think about that
after all you've been through and this
day alone and the many days and years
past how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed university the
choices you made that have brought you
to this day
[Music]
open your heart and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer that's ever needed
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you you're still here
and you get another chance this day to
do better and be better another chance
to become more of who you were created
and what you were created to fulfill
thank you
that's how it starts that is the
foundation for meaning and purpose in
your life is to bring yourself back to
your breath in all situations in all
ways and all challenges to know that the
value of just still being here matters
it's really big that you're here it's a
really big because everybody here has
been called from the ethers to do the
will to fulfill the highest expression
of yourself as a human being and to do
that in truth how do you do that well I
think you let every step you take move
you in the direction of the one thing
all religions can agree on and that is
love there's really only two emotions
that count and that's love and that's
fear and in all of your movements
through life you're either moving in the
direction of one or the other in order
to have a meaningful life you have to
choose love and not the schmaltzy dolts
you kind of love but the kind of love
that really counts the kind of love and
when everything else is going wrong and
nobody even knows you're choosing it you
choose love the kind of love that says
I'm here for you no matter what you
choose love the kind of love that means
you make the right decision even when
you know the other person is wrong you
choose love because love is not just
it's an it's it's a verb and it's
everything that represents kindness and
grace and harmony and cooperation and
reverence for life so when you choose in
the direct when you have you're in a
situation where you are mad you are mad
and you know they are wrong if you can
go to that space of the breath in God I
move and breathe and have my being and
make the choice just to move a little
closer in the direction of that which is
going to bring you grace that which is
going to honor yourself and by honoring
yourself you can't help but honor the
other person I have learned to choose
love over fear to choose love and peace
rather than choosing to be right that
was a big lesson for me if you want some
edmy let affirmations for success check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it and continue to
believe and I'll see you there we all
know someone right now in our life or we
have who's not ethical who's not a good
person who's winning and you're like I
can't believe they're getting it right
why can't I I'm a good person